why'd I call it the lion diet I called
it the lion diet because it's not a cool
diet and you're a total dweeb when
you're on it like you feel like a dweeb
and you're socially weird and it's
really frustrating and you lose all your
favorite foods and you're probably sick
to begin with and I wanted this diet to
have some sort of strong name and be
cooler tried to make it cooler because
being sick sucks and
the all beef diet just sounded so bad so
I guess people might say the lion diet
is cringy but I know that you need a
certain amount of
strength in order to combat chronic
disease and you need that same kind of
drive to do it without the medical
system with diet because that is so
Cutting Edge and so new that people
won't believe you and you need to be
strong and I thought the lion diet kind
of embodied that and lions only eat meat
people are like well Lions don't eat
salt haha are you eating raw meat like a
lion I'm not saying I'm a lion you nerds
just called it the lion diet now does
that end my line diet q a can I squish
one more in here
[Music]
thank you